[Music]
foreign
it was an essentially especially wild
Fourth of July not essential especially
uh at the White House where on Sunday
cocaine was found it's been a lot of
speculation about where it could have
originated and today kjp was pressed on
it how determined is the president to
get to the bottom of the broad legal
drugs Secret Service is getting to the
bottom and that's what matters and it's
under their purview it was the question
was how determined is the president the
president thinks it's very important to
get to the bottom of this he can't get
to the bottom of the stairs how's he
going to get to the bottom of this but
I'll leave that aside one official
familiar with the investigation is
telling Politico the cocaine culprit is
unlikely to be found given it was
discovered in a highly trafficked area
of the West Wing joining us now former
secret service agent Bobby McDonald he
was the assistant special agent in
charge of the vice presidential
protective division when Joe Biden was
VP Bobby Fox's Jackie Heinrich is
reporting that the Secret Service is
conducting DNA and fingerprint tests and
reportedly reviewing visitor logs and
surveillance how long could something
like this take
well good evening Raymond it's nice to
be with you tonight I think the secret
service is going to be utilizing every
asset and capability that it has in its
reach uh they're going to be working
with other agencies that can assist in
this investigation nobody knows that
facility better than the uniform
division officers and the special agents
of the Secret Service who work there
every day they know every nook and
cranny of it they know every place where
videotapes are available they've got the
access to the visitor logs I would
disagree with the comment earlier that
it's a very highly Traverse location it
may be on a Monday through Friday
although I don't think that it's very
highly traversed over a holiday weekend
so my guess is that the secret service
has a fairly good idea uh of who may be
involved in this situation they
definitely have an idea of who was on
the campus that weekend let's talk about
that Bobby the location of where the
coke was found is important originally
it was a library then it was in the west
wing and then this CNN reporter tells us
more about it watch this is typically
where tour groups which can come in
sometimes during the weekend would pass
through in order to get a tour of the
West Wing and also near where there are
Cubbies where people are asked to leave
their cell phone so that is an important
piece of information Bobby I think I'm
familiar with the that area where the
Cubbies are that they're talking about
do Public tours use that entrance
no the Public tours use the entrance at
the East side of the White House this
would be more for specialized tours for
people who are bringing guests uh in and
the people who would be giving the tours
our hard pass holders so they are known
people who work in and around the White
House who have a regular hard pass for
entrance in the wild white in and around
the White House excuse me on a regular
daily basis yeah so so it's it may be
either a staffer or a guest of a staffer
you think that's what you you would
surmise again based upon a holiday
weekend uh the fact that most people who
work in the old executive office
building would not be in and around the
campus sweeps are conducted all the time
in and around the White House as you
know to make sure that there's nothing
that's inappropriate in various
locations so uh the idea that this may
have been in the cubby for several days
uh just doesn't hold water for me okay
Bobby thank you for the Insight hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else